this is the indo-european language
family
it stretches from the north of india all
the way to western europe
almost half of the global population
speaks an indo-european language and
that includes you and me
english is a indo-european language
specifically part of the germanic branch
of the family along with languages like
german
dutch and swedish
in the early 5th century the romans who
had ruled over england for over 400
years withdrew their hold over the
island
filling this vacuum a number of germanic
tribes from denmark in the north of
germany ventured onto the island and
slowly replaced the celtic and romano
british cultures that had been dominant
in the area
celtic speakers became concentrated in
wales scotland and cornwall
while the area we now know as england
became culturally germanic
the germanic peoples in britain well
from a number of separate tribes
eventually developed a common cultural
identity as anglo-saxons
and with these anglo-saxons our story
truly begins
[Music]
the anglo-saxons in their many kingdoms
spoke a language we now call old english
old english really sounds nothing like
our modern language and is largely
incomprehensible to us modern speakers
here's an example of the language from
the epic poem beowulf
what way gardena in yardagom
so i assume you understood none of that
not to worry no modern english speaker
would be able to understand
it's so old and english has evolved so
much that it may as well be a foreign
language while not understandable today
half of our most commonly used words
come from this anglo-saxon tongue
words like water child ear talk and the
basically most short simple words come
from this old english language
now old english was not a static
language no languages ever are but most
of the major changes to the english
language through its history came not
from within
but from without
the first major influx of change to
english came with the viking invasions
in the 8th century onward
norsemen from norway and denmark invaded
the north of england and even set up a
kingdom of their own called the danelaw
these vikings spoke a language called
old norse which is the ancestor of the
modern scandinavian languages its
influence on english was mostly
vocabulary with words like sky
bag law
hit and even they
coming from old norse
[Music]
in 1066 william the bastard later called
william the conqueror invaded england
with his norman army and at the battle
of hastings successfully conquered it
these normans now the ruling class of
england spoke a dialect of old french
this norman french came to be the
language of the royal court
while old english continued to be the
language of the peasantry
after around 100 years of this the two
languages began to merge creating what
we call middle english
if you've ever wondered why english a
germanic language has so many cognates
with romance languages like spanish or
french this is why
a whopping 30 percent or 10 000 english
words are french in origin
these words are most commonly seen in
the spheres of law
religion and
science this french connection is also
why english has so many words that mean
the same thing
called synonyms if you look at an
english dictionary it is almost always
much larger than a dictionary of another
language the most famous example of
these synonyms comes from the realm of
food in english we use two different
words when referring to an animal and
the meat that comes from said animal
words like pig cow and chicken are all
anglo-saxon as the farmers who raised
these animals were english speakers
while pork beef and poultry are all
norman french because the elites who ate
the fine food were french speakers
with this influx of french words as well
as a simplification of the grammar rules
of old english middle english is one
step closer to the language we know
today
still it is by and large
incomprehensible to most english
speakers
here is an example from the canterbury
tales by chaucer the most famous middle
english writer
wanda da preela with his shore asota the
draft of march hath passed it to the
rota and bathed every vine in switched
lacua of which vertu engendered is the
floor
in the 15th century a phenomenon known
as the great vowel shift started
occurring which propelled english into
its early modern version
this vowel shift affected almost all
english pronunciation in quite dramatic
ways we won't get too into the specifics
because i don't want to get into
complicated linguistics but basically
english long vowels like ooh started
becoming shorter diphthongs like oh a
diphthong by the way is basically a
sound made of two vowels
also there were many consonants that
became unpronounced which we now call
silent letters
a good example of this change is in the
word knife
in middle english it was pronounced
kneef
but after the vowel shift the k became
silent and the e
turned to the diphthong
i
as you can see while the pronunciation
of the word has changed the spelling has
not this is one of the major reasons why
english spelling is so notoriously
difficult
so with this change over around 200
years the english language landed in a
place most of us will recognize a good
example of what we call early modern
english is the work of shakespeare
two households both alike in dignity in
fair verona where we lay our scene from
ancient grudge break to new mutiny where
civil blood makes civil hands unclean
that was a small part of the prologue
from romeo and juliet
it is understandable
but the word choice is quite different
from how modern english speakers speak
making it sometimes difficult to
comprehend entirely
beginning in the 16th century the
british started exploring and
subsequently created an empire at its
height in the 19th century the british
empire covered a quarter of the earth
and had control over almost a quarter of
the earth's inhabitants
this spread of english as well as the
later industrial revolution transformed
english even further
mostly in the realm of vocabulary new
words from english colonies as well as
new words for new technology ballooned
the english vocabulary into what it is
today
also the spread of english created many
english varieties most prominently in
north america where english
pronunciation froze in place
the standard american accent like my
accent is actually closer to the accent
of shakespeare than most modern british
accents
american english is particularly
influential because of the success of
american pop culture around the world
english today is still evolving as much
as it ever was with new words being
added to dictionaries every year as well
as many old words falling out of use
english grammar is also changing
and it will continue to change so much
so that in a few hundred years our
language will sound just as foreign to
future english speakers as chaucer does
to us
[Music]